this is a production of cornell
university
thanks so much nina and it really is
a pleasure and an honor to be
addressing my colleagues on this topic
which i've been studying for the past
several years so i'm going to go right
into my powerpoint
and in this talk i would like to address
what is now well known
both about the physical and
psychological and physiological benefits
of time in nature
so over the past 30 years or so
there has been an increasing body of
evidence
that has confirmed that being active and
out in nature or sitting passively
in a natural scene or based on some
studies even viewing a picture
or video of nature can provide
a number of short-term health benefits
and can even provide impact over
many years
the belief in the benefits of spending
time in nature
has precedence that stretch back
thousands of years this is not a new
idea
uh aristotle for example stated
in on the parts of animals
for in all natural things there is
something marvelous
and william shakespeare in his
lesser-known play trollius and cressida
stated
one touch of nature makes the
whole world kind
more recently the famed biologist
and entomologist eo wilson
examined our innate human
affinity for nature and our love
of natural objects in his book
biophilia in the years since
the publication of that book the term
biophilia
has come to be used as a kind of
shorthand for humans love
of the natural world so why do we have
this connection with nature
and how does it affect our bodies
and brains
physiological stress is commonly
monitored through salivary cortisol
levels the higher the cortisol level
the higher the degree of stress
in the body a number of studies
have compared homogeneous cohorts of
individuals who were asked to spend
a set amount of time walking in
a natural setting like a woodland or
along an urban street in every case
every study i have read cortisol
levels declined significantly
for the nature walkers but not for the
urban walkers
there's a wonderful recent book that i
recommend
titled the well-gardened mind
the restorative power of nature
the author stu sue stuart smith
states in one part being out and about
on busy city streets means having to
process
a lot of auditory as well as visual
information and it disrupts
our ability to focus horns
sirens alarms are all intended to put
people on alert
and keep them safe but they drain our
energy in trying to filter them out
navigating a tide of people on a busy
street pedestrian street is exhausting
at the best of times everyone is going
at a different pace
and both our physical and mental space
is under threat in different ways in the
city environment
well what stuart smith
is describing in that passage
is something called attention
restoration
theory which was first advanced by the
two people you see here
stephen and rachel kaplan back in 1995.
it focuses on the amount of time
each of us spend in directed
attention not only making our way along
urban streets but also
staring at computer screens as we are
all doing right now
engaging in conversation attending
classes reading books or writing grant
proposals
as a result of prolonged con
concentration
an individual may show pronounced
signs of attention fatigue
time in nature has been shown to relieve
our directed attention thereby improving
cognitive functioning
such as memory recall and the ability
to perform concentration tasks
an alternate theory was first proposed
by
this individual roger ulrich in 1991
and it is referred to as stress
recovery theory this theory takes
an evolutionary approach and posits that
our sympathetic nervous system is
conditioned to respond to threats
by increasing stress hormones
and preparing us for fight or flight
now that increase in stress hormones
and readiness for fight or flight is
really helpful
if you're about to be attacked by a
woolly mammoth
but it's not so great in our current
stress-filled world so
ulrich proposed that natural settings
activate our parasympathetic nervous
system
allowing us to rest and digest
in a recent interview that ulrich
provided on the design of hospital
gardens
he stated there is a pattern of
evidence that suggests well-designed
gardens
can reduce stress lower blood pressure
and increase the positive aspects
of experiencing nature as gardens
reduce pain nature seems to reduce
pain by blocking stress and
allowing patients to recover themselves
and reduce their discomfort
so in the literature there has been a
lot of back and forth
over the years about whether the
cognitive or brain focus of attention
restoration theory
or the stress recovery focus of
srt is more accurate
and predictive supporters
of art tend to focus on measurements
based on the central nervous system
while supporters of srt tend to base
their measurements on the peripheral
nervous system
there was a fascinating new research
report thank you christopher dunn for
alerting me to it
by emily scott and colleagues called
toward a unified model of stress
recovery
and cognitive restoration
in nature it proposes
a way to unify these theories through
the vagus nerve which links the central
and peripheral nervous systems
scott and her colleagues propose that
stress recovery and cognitive
restoration
co-occur and are bi-directional
they further suggest that cardiac
vagal tone can serve as an index
of both attention restoration and stress
recovery in the human body
so recovery both of our
directed attention from the brain and
our stress mode from
the sympathetic nervous system
other recent research has looked at the
relationship between
urbanization and the increased incidence
of depression or conversely
how spending time in natural settings
can be
associated with declines in depressive
states
gregory bratman from university of
washington
and his colleagues found that one
possible mechanism for this
might be the impact of nature exposure
on rumination rumination is defined
as a maladaptive pattern
of self-referential thought associated
with heightened risk for depression
and other mental illness
they showed that in healthy participants
a 90-minute walk in a natural setting
decreases both self-reported rumination
and neural activity in a part of the
brain
called the subgenial prefrontal cortex
whereas a 90-minute walk in an urban
setting has no such effects on
self-reported rumination
or neural activity
this evidence that a nature walk can
reduce
the incidence of rumination and
resulting
depression could be valuable
as we consider the students with whom we
work or the
colleagues with whom we regularly
interact
other studies have looked at the
relationship
between exposure to nature
and sleep patterns in one study
based on a large national survey of
adults
the researchers found that those
individuals
that have little exposure to natural
settings
had a much higher incidence of
insufficient sleep patterns
especially among men over 65
so this could be due to either
reduced stress levels or
increased exercise in those frequently
going out in nature
or some combination of the two
i have frankly been both impressed
and somewhat skeptical of studies that
have found that
time in nature or living in greener
locations
can positively impact individuals
life spans gaston
and colleagues reviewed all of the
studies that had
been that had been conducted on this
topic through 2016
and published a paper titled residential
green space
and mortality a systematic review
of the 12 studies that fit their
criteria
they found that the majority of results
showed a reduction in the risk of
mortality
because of a reduction in cardiovascular
disease
for residents in the high in the areas
with the highest residential greenness
so it makes sense that lower incidence
of cardiovascular disease would
translate
into longer life spans
another association between stress
depression and longevity may be based
in our telomeres the protective caps
at the ends of chromosomes recent
studies have suggested that chronic
stress
potentially impacts cellular aging
through telomere shortening and
subsequent consequences
on our health shortened telomere length
has been linked
into lincoln likened
to numerous age-related diseases
such as increased cancer risk
diabetes cardiovascular disease
and even dementia this link
can be particularly pronounced in cancer
patients
and their caregivers
yet another fascinating new line of
research
focuses on ways in which plants
themselves
can impact our stress levels
fighting sides are volatile organic
compounds
given off by a really wide variety of
plants from garlics
and other members of the onion family to
oaks cedars locusts
and even pines
when these fighting side molecules
are taken in through our nasal passages
they've been shown to both reduce blood
pressure
by reducing sympathetic nerve activity
and to boost immune functioning
by enhancing natural killer cell
activity and i'll get back to
the nk cells in a moment
hideki kasha wadane a physiologist and
neuroscientist
at kagoshima university in japan
revealed that sniffing linalool
an alcohol component of lavender
has the same effect on a mouse's brain
as feeding it valium but without
the dizzying side effects
a researcher who i greatly admire at the
university of chicago francis
quo has focused on the role
of these natural killer or nk
cells on the physiological
and biological mechanisms underlying
the benefits of time in nature
nk cells are important in
the human endocrine and immune systems
and are associated with boosting immune
functioning
and providing rapid responses to viral
infected cells considerable
evidence now indicates that natural
environments
can enhance the perception percentage
and function of nk cells and
intracellular anti-cancer proteins
in lymphocytes in two japanese
experiments
a three-day trip to a forested setting
resulted in increased nk cell activity
and the expression of anti-cancer
proteins
in both males and females and for the
female subjects
those effects lasted at least
seven days after that trip in the forest
even ordinary soils can benefit
humans in ways that have been revealed
over the past 20 years mycobacterium
vacay
are non-pathogenic bacterial compounds
commonly found in soils when
introduced to mice they stimulated a
group of neurons
which in turn increased levels of
serotonin
which as we know are associated with
feelings of well-being
and happiness and simultaneously
decreased levels of anxiety
and those may not be the only benefits
of spending time around plants and soil
during the second world war finland was
forced to cede a large swath of
territory
known as corellia to the soviet union
and you see that
here in the second half of the 20th
century
the finnish side became modernized while
people on the soviet side maintained
a traditional lifestyle and by the 21st
century
according to a study carried out by
researchers
at the university of helsinki
the prevalence of allergies on
finland side of the border region was
significantly higher
than those people living on the russian
side
and what the researchers have determined
is that the russian kids had more and
more diverse
bacteria on their skin
put simply the finnish youth
were leading overly sterile lives
which negatively impacted the microbiome
of their skin interesting stuff
this point is reinforced by a popular
author
jack gilbert co-author of a book titled
dirt is good the advantage of
germs for your child's developing
immune system and he states that
our addiction to based
uber clean lifestyles is weakening
our children's defenses against illness
of course that was written before the
current pandemic
and practices on cleaning of one's hands
and skin
have certainly been altered by that
so given all of these benefits of time
and exposure to nature
the question naturally arises of
how much time should a person spend in
nature
each week colleagues and i recently
had a scoping review published
in frontiers in psychology that asked
the question
what is the minimum time dose in nature
to positively impact the mental health
of college age students
what we learned is that as little as
10 to 20 minutes two to three times a
week
can significantly reduce
salivary cortisol levels blood pressure
and heart rate increase cognitive
abilities
and recall and improve overall mood
and if all of that is true for 18 to 22
year olds
it certainly should also be true for
younger
and older people
so one of the most important things
i feel that colleges and universities
can do
is to provide for the physical and
mental health
of their students for the past
several years i've been heading up an
approach to
encourage students to spend more time in
nature
to contribute to their overall
well-being
the mission of our nature rx at cornell
program
is to reduce stress and thereby
increase physical and mental health
in students through their engagement
with nature
and to cultivate in students and
increased
appreciation of nature
one component of the nature rx program
at cornell is our student club
when we're not in a pandemic members of
this club
organize things like weekly nature walks
natural area cleanups invasive plant
plant removals geocaching contests
trips to nearby or regional natural
wonders
or indoor events such as
herbal tea tastings
another way of involving students
is through the nature rx course
that i offer i have twin goals
in that course of exposing students
to on campus and near campus
natural areas that they may otherwise
not have discovered
and having each student develop a deeper
and more personal relationship with
nature
we do that through weekly explorations
to beautiful sites through required
readings
and through reflective essays that the
students
write each week
so a companion course is
currently being offered by colleagues
at uc davis and
my partners at uc davis
and i in 2019
had our students take a
nearly identical pre and post
survey after the first class
and after the last class of the semester
and what we were able to ascertain from
those surveys
is as a result of these classes
the students felt more comfortable in
nature
um more likely to go out in nature
if they were extra stressed or anxious
and
to recommend time in nature to
their friends
so in the course of a semester nearly
every member of the student body winds
up
at the campus campus health facility
uh this of course is not a typical year
so the cornell health clinic
is generally not open but
in a typical year many of the students
who arrive at cornell health
are suffering from stress
anxiety depression
sleep deprivation physical cutting
obesity inactivity or
social isolation
for such students who are manifesting
conditions like that one therapeutic
approach
is a nature prescription based on a
concept
that was developed by this individual
dr robert tsar who many of you may
recall
visiting here and speaking in this
series
in september of 19.
czar was the creator of a not-for-profit
firm called park rx america
whose mission is to decrease
the burden of chronic disease
increase health and happiness and foster
environmental stewardship by virtue
of prescribing nature during the routine
delivery of health care
by a diverse group of health care
providers
and park rx america now
works with clinics and clinicians
in over 35 sites around the us and
canada
so for clients who are dealing with
mental
or physical issues prescribing
time in nature may be of real benefit
as part of a total therapy program
initially cornell healthcare providers
were handing out paper nature
prescriptions to students
that said please go out in nature
time in nature is very beneficial to you
and recommended a few sites
that they could go but prescribing
time in nature is now included
as part of a student's electronic health
record
as you can see here nature rx
discussed and recommended
so in the 2019 20
academic year staff at cornell health
had devised a protocol for
confidentially
and anonymously surveying all those
students
who had received a nature rx
prescription
as part of their ehr so that
we could determine the degree
to which this prescription was
influencing the frequency with which
they went out in nature
their overall stress rec levels
and even their academic performance
unfortunately when the pandemic hit
all of this had to be put on hold
so we are hoping to resume
this type of surveying this uh
fall coming fall semester
yet another component of the nature rx
program
is this responsive website
naturerx.cornell.edu
in it we provide photos descriptors
and gps based directions
to 15
natural and horticultural sites around
campus
most of which are managed by cornell
botanic gardens
through their use of this site we
hope that students will come to
recognize
that nature is nearby and
doesn't require a large block of time
to go out and explore nature
especially on a campus like cornell's is
all around us
to further broadcast messages about the
value
of time in nature to all students at
cornell
the cornell health communications team
has developed a series of e-posters
for media walls around campus
like the foyer in the plant science
building on the first floor
and these posters say things like
did you know that time spent in nature
can help improve your exam scores
did you know that time in nature can
improve your
sleep patterns can improve your social
life
can reduce overall stress levels
and for each of these posters you can't
see the fine print
but we do cite studies that have
verified this benefit
i'm also the co-author as nina mentioned
with the late dr greg eels
of the text nature rx improving college
student
mental health that was published by
cornell university press
in 2019 in it
we go in depth into the mental health
crisis
that currently exists on american
campuses
and which has only been exacerbated
by the coronavirus pandemic
we discuss the proven benefits of
spending time
in nature we provide a
stepwide guide to developing
a nature rx program and profile
four campuses including cornell that
have developed
nature rx initiatives
we end the book by considering ways in
which
nature rx programs will figure
into the future of the american
university
for the past couple of years we've also
developed
a nationwide campus
nature network which currently includes
25 campuses across the us
some very large like yale or
uc davis others quite small
the network put on a day-long symposium
this past october sponsored by cornell
and vice president ryan lombardi
and has recently organized a steering
committee
and six working groups to address
communications teaching campus projects
research anti-racism and the annual
symposium
to conclude spending time in nature
should never be seen as a cure-all
for all human maladies but
it can be integrated into therapeutic
approaches
to contribute to overall well-being
for people of all ages
so thank you and at this point
i would be happy to answer questions
from anyone
thank you don that was great oh as
always very interesting things that
i'm sure none of us really knew about
but
are there any questions for don
don this is marvin so there are
urban campuses and then there are fairly
rural campuses or there are campuses
that focus a lot on
outdoor i feel like hamilton
universities have there been studies
done where they've sort of matched
cohorts
you know and compared student stress
levels
on those more rural campuses focused on
outdoor activities versus those that are
very much
in the middle of an urban center i'm not
aware
of any studies that have specifically
addressed that marvin
but there is a new
app that was developed by a research
group
at stanford which using
gps technology is actually quantifying
the amount of green
that is available from a given setting
and one of the points that we make in
the nature rx book
is that typically very urban
campuses like nyu or
university of chicago will borrow
nearby parks as settings where
nature rx programs can be conducted
okay thanks sure
um christopher dunn asks how does
forrest bathing
relate to the points that i've been
presenting so forest bathing
or shiny roku is a japanese
technique that provides
opportunities for people to have
intense and intimate experiences
in primarily woodland settings
so as opposed to
walking through a woodland and
perhaps occasionally checking your
iphone for email in
forest bathing there are a number
of prescribed activities
that allow an individual to develop
that closer relationship with nature
that i was describing earlier
and forest bathing is really catching on
in the u.s there is
a forest therapy association
and i've attended one
of their virtual workshops and they're
wonderful
i was curious how people go about like
um
if if there is a like pretty clear like
defining difference between like what is
natural
um what is not natural and how some
uh a little like you're talking about
like parks and urban environments or
like
um some areas in between like if you
plant like trees along like an urban
sidewalk like
how do you do those like intermediate um
efforts to like add to nature
what big of an impact do those have it's
a really good question
conor and there is some research going
on now to try to
quantify the quality of natural settings
to see if those that are ranked as
being of higher quality actually have a
greater
impact on the benefits that i've been
describing
but i also long ago adopted
the attitude that nature is what we make
of it
so if someone is crossing over
trip hammer bridge and utterly ignoring
bb lake and trip hammer falls
while they stare at their iphone
they're having a less meaningful
or impactful nature experience than
someone who's walking along the sidewalk
on tower road and studying the
red-tailed hawks
that are in the trees so it can be a
very subjective thing but also there is
research going on now to quantify it
manushi has asked haidan having an
indoor plants
in living or study spaces also
have benefit for stress what kind of
indoor plants in such cases
so there is a huge resurgence
of interest in indoor plants currently
uh probably partly uh based
on how much time all of us have been
spending
indoors and yes there have been
studies done by roger
ulrich who i mentioned earlier in this
talk
who has shown that having
greenery in interior environments
can positively impact mood
and reduce overall stress and anxiety
levels
uh and by the way i don't think it makes
a difference
uh what type of greenery
you have
christopher dunn also says uh the point
about telomere length is an interesting
one
and has been shown to decrease in
other stressed individuals telomeres can
regenerate
in younger individuals but not in
older ones so getting younger people
into nature
is really critical so much of the
research that i that
either i'm involved with now or that
colleagues are involved with has
looked at or is looking at the
impact of time in nature on young
children
i've just read a fabulous review
by louise ciaola at the university of
colorado who studied
young people's attitudes about
nature and did that by
conducting a scoping review of many many
previous papers and what she found
is that young people's
interest in nature and young people's
concerns about current environmental
crises
are not necessarily mutually exclusive
that if environmental challenges
are introduced properly and
in concert with introducing young people
to natural wonders that
children can accept the challenges
and understand that they can make small
steps to make a difference
well if there are no further questions
i actually have one uh my name and i
work with the new york state integrated
pest management program
and we have been doing a lot of
education around
pick risk and we hear a lot
that people have rising anxiety about
getting bitten by a tick and that's one
of the things that we're trying to
counter that you can keep yourself safe
while still
enjoying going outdoors i wonder if
you've seen any indications of that
within your studies or
if you feel like it's something that
might need to be addressed as the
condition gets worse
i have not seen any specific studies
that relate to the fear
of ticks although i agree with you
joellen
that um dressing properly
and checking one's body after
a time in nature can
largely mitigate against the risk
of tick bites i have seen several
studies
that specifically address fear
in nature or fear of nature
um everything from snakes to spiders
to simply being unfamiliar
with being in nature due to
having grown up in a very urban
environment
so those fears can be very real
and i think in such cases it's really
imperative
that the individual be introduced in
a supportive and gradual way
to nature sites rather than
being dumped in the middle of the great
smoky mountains
thank you sure well i really appreciate
everyone's questions and comments
and i uh encourage you to
email me if you have further questions
or if you would like me to cite
specific studies that i
included in today's presentation
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu